[Music]
in Karma's a [ __ ] news a [ __ ] got it
he's gonna sleep so bad you have no idea
all right honey bye hit him up I'm a
little bored I'm up I had a mom with
like [ __ ] the whitest moves ever hit
fleas from police into a canal filled
with toxic algae
yeah there's toxic algae yeah what does
it do oh my gosh
oh my god tell me as a superpower tell
me has a superpower now super Superman
toxic Oh
his skin melted off or something do that
he was like I need to jump in there like
part Robson [ __ ] maybe mm-hmm but then
everything you rob is like at the bottom
of the canal now yeah so there have been
a lot of fish and other wildlife that
have been killed by this particular
algae in the water and even people
people are getting sick just by even
breathing it oh [ __ ]
but this fool so he got pulled over and
he got pulled over because he sped past
the cops and as soon as he stopped the
car he jumped out and he ran and he
jumped into the hell gene you tried
making an attempt to swim away but then
that's when he realized I go that's
[ __ ] gross and now I'm gonna show you
guys a video I don't do these cops did
what was happening yeah
it smell bad he's got sick like hose him
down and then like a neighbor let them
borrow the whole bit did he kill someone
or something he leaves his car because
it's not even stolen right so it's his
car he leaves it the cop can just kind
of like okay who owns this car get him
later yeah but he [ __ ] jumps out the
window it starts swimming it's like that
Chinese boy the other change may be the
only reason why he was scared or
whatever it's cuz police said that they
found seven vials of THC oil in his car
okay well it's I don't know so he was
high as [ __ ] he was charged with
possession of a controlled substance and
resisting arrest without violence so he
was really I just wanna know like what
made him realize he's gonna die like did
it burn going down was a few as making
him dizzy said that I smell like human
feces oh my god I thought what he tastes
like toxic algae crusty yeah remember we
were in Orlando we were staying at this
RV and being in the back it was just a
big like manmade pond oh yeah that was
the backyard with those funny ducks yeah
yeah it was man-made it was just a big
[ __ ] square it was so perfectly
landscape there
a whole bunch of ponds everywhere in
Florida yeah I don't know why is it to
control the water alligators
see oh that's what I be afraid of is
like jumping into that an alligator
coming up and bitin my dick off or
something you know what would he jump
into this yeah there's no and so he's
saying that he's still having
respiratory and stomach problems the
funny thing is he did that for like the
lowest crime ever right yeah that's like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] a speeding ticket yeah
oh speaking respitory i almost died this
past week I had a newt like I hired a
new cleaner to clean the house and she
sure what does she use [ __ ] she made
that poison chlorine with leitzel oh no
she pretty much like chlorine gas and
then like she came running out of the
bathroom like yeah like what she gets
I absolutely mix cuz she had Lysa and
she saw my clerk my Clorox and she
thought if she mixed it too then it
would clean better but she made a
[ __ ] like mustard gas instead and so
like she flushed it open the window she
ran out she was like she flushed it yeah
yeah see because if she leaves it like
festively not supposed to mix chlorine
and though anything about water yeah
because especially ammonia people die
from that [ __ ] so my mom's always mixing
[ __ ] yeah you can't do it cuz no wonder
says the way she is coughing dude she
was coughing like her eyes while she
couldn't breathe I had to send her home
I was like holy [ __ ] like I don't want
you to die here I wonder what that
thought process was chemical chemical
dirty is your house it's just like I
need some strong [ __ ] [ __ ] it
was two toilet bowl cleaners so she
decided to just like you know like hope
she was using a glass no but I thought
so bad like she had to go home and then
what about you um I didn't breathe it in
thankfully and I had a dog with me to
decide to make sure she doesn't go near
the room so we let it air out for a
while but then like she had to like grab
her stuff so she like wrapped her face
up and went to the bathroom grab her
stuff yeah she was coughing bad yeah
it's funny how she's been cleaning for
quite a while like this is her job she's
been a cleaner but this is the day she
decides to be a little bit experimenting
she wanted to make a good first
impression the moral of the story is
never mix bleach with anything about
water or don't hire that
lady but she seems like an overachiever
she's nice
okay fine we'll hire I feel like I might
I might have believed with AJ my mom
always did weird thing AJ that's what
she did see because she was like I
didn't think it'd be a problem because I
usually mix my bleach with Ajax yeah it
makes a page so I guess that I mean if
you didn't die from it but it was really
few me though I remember being like
reading chemicals [ __ ] scare me you
like those no I couldn't breathe and
then yeah yeah like we currents were
like you have to make sure that the
bathroom is clean I loved them when they
came out with CLR as a kid cuz I said
like praying all the bathrooms but the
once you have CLR you could just spray
the whole thing is walk away for like 15
minutes I had a good mom CLR is got
[ __ ] yeah it's like it's usually like
a gray container Oh around yeah it's
alright but I think that should is
pre-mixed
cuz you can't even stand there when
you're spraying it are you gotta cover
your face and they'll run away there's
some strong [ __ ] bashes I used to clean
my own bathroom just now are you serious
you make her clean it I don't make her
she does it for me because she loves me
that's the key is with you and you're a
mess oh right a fact in yourself if you
boil fly wait wait wait I didn't finish
my story so when I used to clean my [ __ ]
right when I used to clean my bathroom
right I would do CLR all those things
but I would rinse the [ __ ] out of
everything for like an hour and not
touch that [ __ ] for a day until all the
air goes out because I feel like the
chemicals are gonna get on my skin and
burn it off I [ __ ] hate chemicals I
didn't like the smell of chemicals
I [ __ ] hate cleaning stuff I feel
like that shit's worse than a dirty
bathroom I rather have dirty [ __ ]
moulding bacteria than chemicals yeah
guys know I love this for my military
buddies if you boil flypaper
you know the flytrap sticky papers it
releases like cyanide guess what
and then that's how you kill people yeah
that's not a good idea no no that I
would you share that with all these
people that are watching right now I'm
not responsible for what you do it's not
responsible for anything that you do
okay it should be monitoring you good
call
you know if you're a kid watch nightmare
parents need to wear your penlight very
little room or not your parents
I like these pops though the reaction
was very professional professional I bet
you they're like holding it in and then
after they're gonna laugh you're gonna
watch it over like but they've seen it
all in Florida they're just like okay
wait okay no I have a cop friend former
cop friend and he the worst thing that
he did he pulled someone over in like a
shady shady town it was like 3:00 in the
morning pulls him over this guy's
heavily drunk intoxicated high out of
his mind and he's trying to explain like
officer the reason I'm like being shady
and driving like this is because I'm
drunk
I need courage because I'm going to like
an organized threesome yeah so it gets
really intense so then they're like okay
well we need to search your car whatever
the entire trunk was filled with dildos
so he wasn't alive yeah but he was
saying like it was to the brim of dildos
selling them at the this orgy we don't
know what is he gonna be a [ __ ]
porcupine of dicks he's gonna suction
come back just pick one threesome like
cuckolding or whatever he's watching in
Harrogate so he is doing the whole thing
hey what is that again like guy watches
that his wife has sex with another man
oh so he was the one that's [ __ ] the
chick and someone is watching so he's
gonna be the one [ __ ] but then he
says God may God like they sent him away
like he was rejected because he didn't
look like the pictures it's like a
really cool team are you watching yeah
your former friend like I thought yeah
the reason why I quit the force no he
just he's like a comedian now oh he was
just like this isn't for me so now he
does like podcasts about like former cop
gays and that was
the weirdest thing you know lots of
unpacking that story room oh [ __ ] he
said it was a weirdest thing like he
seemed like a nice time is it like as
usual gig that we should be charged one
sort of gradual collections like we use
are they brand new dildo cuz they had to
look at all the dildos maybe for work
maybe for personally itemized each that
you put it on top of a champagne bottle
and you shake it then it shoots yeah
yeah a lot of interesting dildos out
there isn't there there's alien ones
that put like fake eggs in you what the
like those weird Japanese people there's
like these dildos where you put like
these fake eggs and slime in it and you
put in you then you can like inject the
eggs to pretend that you're having an
alien baby because whatever the [ __ ]
nowadays it's 2018 so what's that
technology store at the mall because I
think I see some stores yeah I think I
see some dildos there no personal
massager family-friendly no there person
you don't look like dildos though they
just look like a [ __ ] massager that
looks like a u or like a bee or like
look all super like hmm dildos they look
like little [ __ ] oh hi braiders and
you can smell them to this ceiling where
people have been using them what the
how's your hand doing
[Music]